لكن بينما تشاهدون الساعه الستون الان
هناك اكثر من 138 مليون مستخدم امريكي
نشاط للتطبيق الذي تشتر واشنطن على انه
خطر كما ان الحظر لم يمنع الامريكيين من
تنزيله 210 مرات ملايين مره ماذا يعني ذلك
مشاهدينا يعني انا التيك توك يمتلك قاعده
بيانات لاثنين واربعين في المئه من سكان
الولايات المتحده ونصفهم من البالغين ومن
وجهه نظر او بالاحرى اتهامات الصناع
القرار السياسي والامني الامريكيين فان
هذه البيانات ليست فقط في متناوليات
الحكومه الصينيه بل استخدامها ومن ينفي
الاتهامات
مؤسسه الشركه جان يمينك لكنه في الحقيقه
ومنذ 2019 يقع بين فكي كماشه الحكومه
الصينيه تفضل موت التطبيق على ان يتم
الاستحواذ عليه امريكيا عموما فكره
الاستحواذ انتهت بمجرد وصول الى البيت
الابيض ولا يعني ذلك انه وادادرته غير
قلقين خاصه حين يستند الهاجس الى بيانات
الاستخبارات الاف بي اي يفتح قضيه
استخبارات مضاده متعلقه بالصين
10 ساعات وبطبع مدير المكتب كان يتحدث عن
تيك توك وجميع تطمينات الشركه لم تنفع حتى
ما تعهدها باحتفاضها ببيانات المستخدمين
في برجيه ونسخه احتياطيه في سنغافوره بل
حسب موقعي بسيد الذي احتفل بلبل على مستوى
الامن القومي الامريكي بعد حصوله على
تسريبات في المدراء تنفيذيين في توك فان
مسؤوله الشركه في الصين كانوا لا يزال
يصلون الى بيانات المستخدمين الامريكيين